la violencia volvió a empañar un partido
en el mítico maracaná
tras una decisión judicial sin
precedentes las barras del flamengo del
Vasco de Gama del fluminense del
botafogo están vetadas en todos los
estadios de una ciudad que respira
fútbol también está prohibido el acceso
a las sede social de estas barras cierre
total de nuestro inmueble que es de la
barra joven
en esta oficina guardan todo el material
publicitario de la afición como
camisetas banderas y gorras
Tendremos que hacer un recurso ante la
justicia para intentar que nuestra se
devuelva a funcionar normalmente
Esta es precisamente la estrategia que
están siguiendo a pesar de ser Rivales
en el campo las barras de Río de Janeiro
se han Aliado para librar una larga
batalla judicial
esta reunión es importante para que
todas las barras se pongan de acuerdo y
para mostrar a la fiscalía general y a
la jueza que dictó esta sentencia que
todas las barras están en sintonía
Aunque apoyan un equipo diferente estado
unidas estamos juntos en el mismo
propósito
cuentan con el apoyo de la orden de los
abogados conocida por su lucha a favor
de la Democracia durante la dictadura
militar Estamos de acuerdo que encomió
el crimen que pague que sea identificado
a través de su cédula y que pague de
acuerdo a la ley pero no puede pagar
toda la organización porque eso no pasa
con ninguna otra institución si se trata
de un funcionario público es Unido si es
un policía es suspendido Por qué con las
barras es diferente
la conmebol ha decidido que la final de
la Libertadores será en el maracaná el
mismo estadio en que la violencia forzó
El veto a las barras el pasado 5 de
marzo